welcome to the last word episode number
96
yes Allah the glorious Friday with back
from the campfire for some more looters
shooter discussion I'm a super excited
about a special guest so we gonna get
right into it I wanna introduce the Lord
whose passion for the destiny franchise
and positive vibes the content creator
truly reflects the strength of our
gaming community whether it be his
dedication to the eSports team or his
passion for streaming all done in good
fun and trademark you introducing the
executive producer for Team MV the
Dallas Empire and the Dallas fuel the
Capitan of twitch and yet another proud
Titan main live from Dallas Texas and
making his debut at the campfire of the
last word mommy
Lord captive McFly how you doing sir
doing well gentlemen thank you so much
for having me on and I will say I will
not say Titan main I I do love all
classes equally there we go I just have
yes I am an omni class Oh like honestly
if I really had to say like for for d1
warlock is what really kind of what I
took to and then right before honestly
it was near the end of house of wolves I
started to rotate and start to play more
heroes and stuff because I was thinking
you know like I'm getting a little burnt
out and so I started to play different
classes because it was just a different
way to play the game and then when taken
King came out I'm like okay Solar Titan
sunbreaker with like a hammer it's like
a war simulator 2.0 let's go I remember
when AK DLC killed and still even today
like that sound effect like the shoot
yeah fear of that sound effect when you
heard that in a crucible yeah oh yeah
and so I've circled back to being a
Titan again and because I did hunter for
a while like I when I came back to I did
I want to say I did warlock for forsaken
and then I rotated to Hunter and then
now I've rotated back and so usually I
try to like either hop around
big deal seat releases or major seasonal
updates and stuff just to kind of just
to keep things moving it key it makes
things that like that extra fresh that
new that much more new because it's
either been so long since I've played
something and so it kind of like I don't
know it enhances the fun for me and then
and also like especially in crucible it
keeps me up to date on like who can do
what like really respected let's think I
give you credit yeah I could definitely
say like I definitely do better though
as Titan or warlock hunter like I've
yeah I respect people that can move so
much and be so quick with it but for me
it just did the it's really the ability
just don't quite work well for me in my
mind like the the subsidies you can do
as a Titan in a warlock like I'm like
okay cool this makes sense in a PvP
standpoint dodge duck dip dive and dodge
hunters as you kind of phrase that
perfectly is like the mobility and
dodging jumping get in get out the stuff
that some people can do like watching
miss 5,000 watts do some of the stuff
she does with some of like this you know
hunters are crazy
yeah like even like in a d1 like
cirshades step like Lumi watching him
just move around it's like dude how does
he do it and like how does he think this
way it's like it's amazing and it's so
weird when you go back and look at that
footage and stuff and you see him
playing on PC now I'm like wow d1 was so
slow yes that's so fast oh yeah so we've
got a fellow PC master-race er here with
us or console brethren or just all of
the above
uh so I was console on destiny right up
until a couple months before Forsaken
and I've come back to PC a large part of
his because once I started working in
eSports I was surrounded by people that
were in PC and I just felt the peer
pressure to like oh yeah so what does
your quick is so top couple games that
pop in your head what do you got for old
school new school what's like favorite
games of all time kind of like favorite
games of all time we kind of we
got to get a few in there but just
anything that comes in doesn't have to
be like the ultimate laminated list from
friends or anything so it's sure so like
for me like I'm a big fan of Zelda and
so but specifically like ocarina is
probably the game really made me fall in
love with the series when I was a kid
because we had my sister Knight and n64
that was a game that I would wake up and
my sister and I would wait for the
school bus but we would play Zelda
upstairs and just run around on the
horse and Hyrule and just kill stuff in
the fields of Hyrule and then just like
just run around and like make a game
within the game for ourselves we just
loved playing the game and then for
shooters and stuff battlefield 1942 on
PC was a game I sunk serious hours into
and would try to just you know go Scout
class and just snipe people and try to
get no deaths at all or only one death
and so you'd get like 41 in one or
things like that or like basically keep
people from getting into airplanes it
was just for some reason like it was so
fun it at the time like I was a real big
world war ii buff and so it was like it
was like double um Bioshock is still a
game that has you know huge positive
memories for me music yeah such a good
game and then Mass Effect is which is
kind of what part of like piqued my
interest for destiny yeah like Mass
Effect is such a good series and I'm a
little sad that in drama but I just kind
of fell a little bit laughs but I still
I still loved the series it doesn't sour
it for me it just makes me you don't
talk about it yeah and then even she was
like COD like I mean I played Cod 1 on
PC and that stuttered to really get me
into competitive shooters when cod 1
came out I played a little bit of
counter-strike and was OK at it but I
really liked cod 1 mainly because of the
world war 2 setting but I started
playing and online leagues like Carol
and twl which are like I don't even know
if those websites are ladder leagues or
even still a thing but I would do like
pickup games with like mirc and like
just hugs and stuff yeah and so you know
we said
people to use if IRC is still there if
you don't know it is look it up there
may be some research for our guests
today so Google yeah will have an index
of terms at the end of the episode
Wow but like that's really what got me
into like competitive shooters and Italy
started like getting me into that
because like I played sports in high
school too it's like I'm just a very
competitive guy and I'd like to I like
to go against people that either are
better than me or I can try to best them
that's what draws me to PvP so much and
why I even though with trials like
that's why sometimes I can getting a
little salty right now cuz it's
sometimes and we'll discuss a little bit
but it's sometimes like I'm losing
fights it's not because I'm better but
it's because they have a advantage that
I can't overcome and so if I miss power
left right I'm sure we'll talk about
that later so and even then like what
I'm saying salty it's like it's one of
those where it's like I wish I could get
more time in because I know I could beat
him yeah and but then destiny too like
honestly destiny is my to me is the
perfect game for someone like me because
it combines my love for a good shooter
with loot like Diablo and World of
Warcraft
I played way too much Wow when I was in
high school and early college oh yeah
right and then it combines that together
and even though yeah the story isn't
quite presented to me like I was hoping
it was gonna be like a massive X tile
thing I still enjoy the lore that's
within the game and it's so fascinating
to me and being within our own solar
system for me being just a dork makes me
just it's awesome yeah talk about it's
quite the quite the history there oh
yeah between Diablo world
you got Mass Effect you got fans on both
sides of this podcast so you're in great
company he's going I like games man
games are fun oh yeah
I've been played like 8-bit Nintendo
them and playing since and it sounds
like we're all at least that old so
we've been playing in a two boomer okay
that's right well see you are involved
in and then I wanted to ask you as well
so you're like your journey into just
eSports and stuff like that kind of just
a little history of how you got into
actually being part of like pretty big
like situation down here in Dallas like
kind of how'd that happen what's a quick
little history and just like what have
you what's your experience in like being
around people in eSports and how do you
see that like growing just that whole
field of everything going on I just okay
so you can go sure it's a big Jan so
like professional history for me is that
I started working in television about
six seven years ago but did that for a
while and then during that time I was a
camera operator technical director DP
kind of you know slowly worked my way up
in terms of responsibilities
professional experience and then over
time I really one of my favorite clients
really let me get a chance to go to a
lot of different gaming events knew a
lot of event coverage like it III pax
all that kind of stuff and it's like
okay I want to get into games media
there's not much here in Dallas they can
do that like most things are most things
are out west like they're out in San
Francisco like the ign's and the game
spots and giant bombs and stuff like
that and so my I talked to my wife a
little bit about it I'm like hey I
really want to make this career pivot
but we might have to move and she's like
please try to find something in Texas
because I don't wanna I don't want to
leave our families and things like that
and so it's like alright so knowing that
it slowed the search down a little bit
and even like even working for someone
like Bungie like I was even trying to
look at stuff like that - like studios
that I really really liked or even Sony
Santa Monica seeing if there's any like
anything media related that they would
be hiring for and then the position here
at NV got listed I got a tip from a
producer that I used to work with and
she's like hey I had lunch with which
who then became my boss at the time
Justin Rojas she's like hey you know
they're gonna be doing a listing for for
a producer position here
keep your eyes peeled on this it's
probably gonna go up tomorrow and so I
just stared at zipper crews like 24
hours just waiting Bertha was like are
you gonna sleep I haven't blinked in 24
hours and just it's like no no no this
thing is coming like resumes ready just
you know tweak the cover letter to make
it catered in this thing and the listing
came through and I looked through what
they were looking for and qualifications
it's like I don't have to lie about any
of this right and so it's like cool I
can do this
like it's it's one of those like you
know sometimes when you see job listings
you're like I could do like 70% of what
they're asking yeah this one's like I
can do yeah I don't have to be ask them
on this like I can straight-up say yes I
can do this for you and so I put the
resume in and you know did the interview
and everything and you know eventually
got the gig and started out it's just a
producer and then we've had a because
with envy is still very much like a
small company and so people still get
shift around and then so now Justin's
over leading events and then I kind of
got shifted up to more of like a mid
management role and so now I'm executive
producer for all of our content but now
I'm specifically focusing on our live
stuff you know because of the the
quarantine situation we've had to like
silo people so that everybody can like
just really focus in on like certain
teams and things like that
while we're separated just to keep
things as efficient as we can be because
everybody's got a different internet
where they're at but yeah I got into
working over here and you know working
in eSports making different kinds of
content whether it's like meme stuff
reviews shows but it's cool though
because the fun thing is it's all
centered around games but it also it's
it's a big pivot from you know studio
production going to this because it's
very much like you have full sound
stages now down to you're almost you're
above indie in terms of your resources
you don't you're it's a lot more like
rolling up your sleeves everybody's
doing a little bit of everything which
is also very common for the media
industry in Texas and everybody does a
little bit of everything so but it's
been fun though I've really dug it a lot
and had a chance to meet a lot of cool
people and we're you know making some
cool shows about the call of duty league
and overall
League that we do live twice a week on
Tuesdays and Fridays on Envy TV check us
out it's a new channel that we're plug
it all you want yeah yeah yeah yeah so
if you are into those things if you're
into overwatch League and Cod League our
hosts are fantastic and we are doing the
shows remote right now because it co vid
but the studio setup that we have for
our first two episodes should give a
pretty good idea of you know what we're
kicking out in terms of what we're
capable of and so it's fun though like
it's it's a great gig yeah like I've
been tripping into the dream job there
but pretty much yeah like there's
there's not much it's basically as close
to a dream job as I think I could get as
far as like what I professionally can do
and video games like this mention that
as close together as possible also yeah
so awesome well if you guys haven't
caught this guy before he streams on
Twitch as well Captain McFly so catch
him on there he's got an awesome
following so very cool group Bob's art
as well thank you Bob as hard for coming
in he was on here on here a little while
ago so yeah well we actually do play
destiny so we may as well talk about
that a little bit right yeah sure so
this week in the world of destiny - we
got a new bunker that one opened up a
short little tiny discussion with Anna
and then we've also got trials going on
this weekend but it is kind of the two
weeks before we get things unlocked so
just going on to kind of see how much
you guys have been playing iron banner
kicked off this week and just wanted to
see what you guys have been feeling what
you've been seeing anything you've been
working on how's the week starting out
for you guys so I did get a chance to
check out the new bunker and was a
little disappointed to see that Anna was
a blade barrage hunter I was like no
should be like at least like a I don't
know like because she did the knife in
in the first bunker cutscene so it's
like okay sweet maybe maybe this is
gonna hint at blade dance they're coming
back alright so I don't know that's what
I hoped for cuz to me like the way that
she looks in the way like how acrobatic
and how she moves it's like dude she
should totally be
you know like spectrally if there's
something you know like it's just it
seems like for that power fantasy
because Cait is the gunslinger so I
wanted her to like at the very least be
a different subclass yes yeah but even
then it's like all right cool the bunker
was like mm-hmm another bunker I did
like the hive extra aesthetic that was
added to it I think that's cool the
event itself though like for me is I
hear it's not discussed it's like it's
the replayability for it for me someone
who could for someone like me and I'm
I'm a husband I'm a father
and you know I work you know 45 50 hours
a week I only get two game three nights
a week so if I'm gonna spend my time
grinding an activity I want to at least
enjoy the activity for you know the four
or five hours I'm gonna get that night
and it's just the the reap the gameplay
loop on that for me is not that
enjoyable for me personally and it's not
that I just like PvE I do love PvE but
it really it's a I don't know it's it's
not as dense as I hoped it would be
I kind of wanted to see maybe some more
variety in terms of like maybe having
more rotation in terms of like things
that you find within the bunker or
making it feel like yeah but it's
basically the same thing different
location from easy to moon I was maybe
hoping for something that's very
different from zone to zone whether
that's just the actual structure of the
bunker right in turn to like the
hallways and everything that like okay
because I know it went down a staircase
and turned I was like oh here's a little
too hallway thing okay here's this
little lake it I don't wanna again never
I hate like throwing you know shade
anything it like developers and the time
that they've gotten stuff like that but
I was like color this hallway here put
this one here boss room rotate like it's
almost the same it feels like it really
much yeah and I understand that you know
this is we're seeing Bungie for the
first time on there
no support studios and things like that
and so I do I do give a lot of grace in
that in terms of how I'm feeling about
it but it doesn't negate my experience
from how I've been taking in and
digesting the content so it's one of
those things like it would be something
I would hope to see if we do an event
that's similar to this whether it's a
warmind or a thing that's gonna be same
thing here but similar on different
planet like having more variety in terms
of the presentation so that as we're
going down into that area or beginning
that mission that we're not like oh I
know exactly where to go because I just
did this for a week right or two weeks
it's the point yeah
and so like at the same time like I
appreciate what it is I like to we're
getting to do stuff with Rasputin I
think that's cool I think it's
interesting that he's the you know our
main NPC that we engage with and it's
not an ax or Zavala I kind of hoped for
a mission kind of like we had like with
Cade at the beginning of forsaken or
like any mission that we can do
something that is with the NPC in a
mission I think is something that I
would love to see more going forward
because it really it adds that
interpersonal experience with you and
the hero even if it's like fully
scripted and like even in the beginning
of d2 when soval is like on the tower
like that's we've never fought with
Zavala we've never seen I Korra just
wreck house and like take down a ship on
her own just you know like yeah and like
stuff like that like it matters in a
campaign and so we're just in a
single-player experience so I I just I
hope some of that tries to find its way
back and I was hoping we were gonna get
that with Anna and Zavala and I was
really excited for that am i cool Anna
who we really know very little about and
then Savola who gets a lot of flack for
just being you know mr. either lawful
good or just stubborn I was hoping for
like a good you know conflict yeah yeah
and then like some kind of a
reconciliation and then maybe like a
thing with the community maybe starting
to really like Zavala like having this
like not redemption of is avala but like
a position to where his story could you
know pivot and then you know he could
become one of the most liked characters
in the universe you know with the void
that we have from you know no longer
having Kade mm-hmm there's room for NPCs
to now get that love from God in the
community I mean same kind of boat she
dies on you know it opened up it was on
the moon you know very similar I must
admit you know got in there and uh I
don't know is it me or is it feel like
the actual was it what is it called
what's the actual name of it the serif
our public event on the surface or the
surface
yeah the serif tower yep the surf town
so it is we if it was like the moon one
is easier to protect I don't know I felt
like the eighties got for the enemies
had a little bit more higher level now
aren't you well that too but I also feel
that they that the the AI I don't know
if it's just because it their hive down
that I felt like the Fallen was sneaky
like you you know you got that yeah for
sure yeah you know what I mean like they
go invisible it was tricks and stuff
that would get them on that plate to
prevent yeah you know jumping off
whereas the hive I see them a mile away
and I'm like okay it is this it's pretty
straightforward except when they put the
big old sure you almost have like the
difference of like vandals who are gonna
like go on all fours and run at you real
bright or Marauders the invisible versus
like raster all they're like yeah yeah
that's kind of like NPC like design
differences though you know like fallen
are much more tactical yeah not as
tactical it's like the ball but like you
know hive I wouldn't say are stupid but
they're more better served in tight
spaces you know kind of yeah rota raid
and stuff know they're meant they're
meant to be overwhelming in a very tight
space yeah you could see what I what I
was thinking yeah exactly like is even
on the moon to like the nights are a big
pain even out in the open cuz if they've
got that shield they can still they have
time to close the gap on you a little
bit if you're not careful and Shriekers
to like honestly the night
it can be a pain in the biscuit because
it's like if you don't have anywhere to
go like if you were to any open you're
in trouble I got that out you know got
back in there you know little surprised
to see that the Bounty's then shifted
also only to that bunker which surprised
me somewhat cuz I went back to easy easy
see I'm almost finished with easy I just
like a little nose I got to do but
although I mean same kind of thing you
know um I wasn't discussed it but I'm
just like oh okay
more of the same you know that kind of
bit so that's been there for me I got
the at the light level up got four
horsemen finally done yeah but I was fun
I had fun with the lost sector a bit
stuff like that shot the boycott box who
helped me with that and yeah just been
chillin you know say just been chillin
just doing that and I was he waiting for
trials to come back around so I can come
back in the mix you know but um yes
you've been playing in the iron banner
yes a lot of iron banner now put high on
Wednesday to mean you play survivor what
yes we did actually I know a partisan
Cognito site II they lose they get it in
okay leading the leaderboards the mister
I don't play PvP but always finds his
way at the top definitely not always I
do all the things he was doing these
things child the stone stone will be a
guy's grew baby stole we had screaming
it like a six pack rather than therefore
yeah so then just the Attic the crew so
we got some ban and going you know I'm
always gonna like I mean it's just it is
what it is I've always I'm a pvp duck
but um you know I will say after I
experimenting with hard light you know
you can't beat them join them
it is yeah it's so it is it is but it
isn't it isn't it isn't gonna be a hard
light apologist here but I will say
there are still ways to beat somebody
that is using hard light break it down
sure and honestly this is just more so
just destiny crucible philosophy and
let's go I'm about this yeah this is
part of what makes destiny good compared
to earn it makes it unique in terms of a
game like Call of Duty which is more
like if you if you were seen
first you're dead first yeah more than
likely whereas in destiny very much like
hallo you have the ability to have at
least a moment to you know right you
know retreat reset and re-engage
sometimes now with trials it's maybe not
as not as easy to do it because of the
power differences but if someone is
using hard light you need to force them
to make a decision that's gonna make
hard light not viable so you like you
know using your radar within doors and
stuff get them to come forward use your
teammates to make that player look
somewhere else you maybe have to do a
1:1 trade if you have to or make them
make a decision like you know spread
have like team fire you know work with
your team like if you're if you know
you're dueling a hard light and you're
not rocking hard light then you either
need to know that you're Johnny Snipes
and you're gonna put him down on that
first click every time because a bit of
a thing that I saw I think Giggs tweeted
it out and I didn't know that it was a
thing but energy weapons have inherent
extra flinch just across the board so if
you're sniping know that you're flinch
is gonna suck that much more with your
flinch but if you know you're gonna get
that click every time then you can duel
them that way you know you can poke put
them down like that's a good way to put
them in otherwise you need to force them
tighter rock your shotgun or if you're
like me and you you're you know the way
of the voop and still still still do
still movement I try to poop it when I
can I tried to pick up sniping because I
wanted my aim to get better and so I've
heard from different players and
different people that I work with they
say if you really want to improve your
aim and do stuff like put yourself in a
position where you have to elevate your
play because if you don't you're not
challenging yourself and the more you
keep doing it you're gonna eventually
just get the reps and do it like even an
overwatch like when I was switching from
console to PC the thing I was told is
pick mechanically the most difficult to
move and use heroes because it's gonna
force your muscle memory to kick back in
and have to just use everything so I
just started rocking wrecking ball like
most all this shirt yeah it's like if
you're doing like a hard light I mean
I've heard some people say to that you
know suros can out pace hard light
even worse I yeah yeah and so I haven't
had much personal experience to prove
that if all things are equal so because
the plus side of moon was service you do
get that chance for health regen so like
I think overall crucial philosophy like
yeah you may have a chance to survive
that to be one if you're rockin Souris
versus hardlight you know if you're if
you're putting everything on the same
playing field like shots or shots is
hard light strong yes very very strong
is it as strong as people are thinking
no because I've still some I've seen and
gone against people that are still
rocking their spare rations they're
still you know I've seen people he's
been bringing out Sun shot recently I've
seen that starting to become a thing
yeah so it's still like 150 rpm hand
cannons are still very much in the
conversation it's just more people are
able to get hard light and being able to
just rock an auto rifle is a little bit
simpler than rocking a hand cannon when
you're punished for missing sure I mean
it's more so like to get shots downrange
you're gonna get more bullets downrange
and have a higher statistical chance of
hitting something with an auto than a
hand cannon that's it's you know up to
what 14 shots versus 46 or 36 or
something like that it's right you know
just the odds are a lot more in your
favor with an auto connecting especially
with ricochet rounds like oh man yeah
yeah look he's decent and give heart
light time to shine look at how long
spear benders Russians and many Russians
and Mindbenders but listen I get they're
still meta - there's still meta you know
say at the end of the day my own my
issue with Harley is just like I said
when he pulls up the the numbers and we
see the disparity from number one to
number two it's so you know that that's
my issue you know saying I don't mind if
it was like I say four I'm throwing up a
fictional number let's say it was three
million and then number two is two
million Oh
right but when one gun is like seven
five million the other the next is like
two dandasan
but honestly he said it probably
perfectly as you've got ease of access
it's a it's an exotic most people have
had for a very long time pull it from
the collections of two it's an auto
rifle so as you said it's an easier
thing for a lot more people to use so
even the people like and the reserve -
yeah he's bad but the buff for sure but
even like me average Joe Schmo and PvP
like they're gonna at least try with
that so even the people who may not be
getting as many games in like Grenadier
Jake who goes 55 times flawless or
whatever and craziness that man did they
may get more time in there but even the
average player is still probably gonna
just try that one first because you also
said spare Russians harder to grind
Mindbenders ambition harder to grad like
the plan B ease of just like by the way
try to go get them yeah yeah if you want
one there they're available this week
but yeah it's just like those take
farming most people if they played some
over the course of the past two or three
years I have able to pull that one so
even just the ease of attempting trials
they're like well I hear this thing's
good I see laser light oh yeah let me go
pull it out just it's a hole that's a
probably another reason it's probably
climbing up easier it's one gun but
every single person has so the map to I
think maps also sometimes or maybe only
not more there's like yeah anything CQC
with with hard white I think is where it
shines like a very tight place where
ricochet can play a factor you know I
really want to see the numbers when we
play widows court okay I should go I
have a feeling that's gonna be the map
on Friday now we'll say this to your
defense looks like I do i do see snipers
out there still mobile of its out
they're still moving I'm seeing it and
I'm not a sniper at all and I actually
love to see it
you don't say cuz I'm not okay these are
still viable so done percent reliable to
me I still like my T's heartily I love
the meta
I still think everything else is still
pretty much competitive it I'm having
fun with a lot of stuff so yeah
see the new trials weapons that drop the
shotgun or whatever yeah Astra horizon
yeah I got a shout my boy cross out
video you know he gave up what about
secrets gilliard ban Gilly on if you've
been doing a black armory 600 rpm energy
auto that it's a ridge I don't know if
you can farm from it from the auto
bounty I'm not shirking I may give that
may give the ringing nail that's what
you get from like the Ford saboteurs or
something like the world
gilli yard row it's dirty yeah it's
really good what's your role on it I
believe I got rampaged snapshot nice ok
energy auto dad yeah it's really nice
man you get the rangefinder on it or
some dynamics way you're good and that
thing's record I'm seeing people reckon
with that too so it's what are you
rocking in your in your kinetics lot
with that kinetic um kind of flip-flop
right now actually doing so far I got me
a nice pillager SMG mmm the subway I got
an outlaw outlaw believe on you that
look kill clip I believe what it Oh
perfect what bro it's asked question
you're ready to put him down and then
swap - yeah right over the door I've
been doing that and then shoddy got me a
nice Hawthorne's um it's kind of the
best you know shoddy I have in kinetic
that's kind of PvP base will have to
marry EVP kind of rolls or my kinetic
shoddy outside of a paradox with my
Hawthorne's the range is just so much
more so yeah yeah I just said other ones
is still viable I think people just
pread forgotten about it cuz it's a
lunch DTV no again it's not gonna pop
and back up yeah by rolls on that have
been terrible but I've seen a couple
minik oh come on give me a good one not
yet
yeah but I do think even though hard
light is really it is you know I've seen
your number Z and I've seen him on I see
it on my feet all the time like hardly
this hard like that and I'm of the mind
that and I I did this a lot in Destiny
one too like I am stubborn and I'll try
to go against the meta that's what
because like even in Indy one like near
the very end of it I was rocking
sunbreaker with garrison and I did last
word salad individual that was that was
my loadout and so I would I'd be hyper
aggressive but I had a snapshot
hand-laid stock and I forget what my
other perk was for my vigil but it was
good like I could time it to poop and
with snap or yeah with a snapshot that
80s was just that much quicker so
whenever I would do it it would tighten
that bolt down as it would go
and so that was not many people used
fusions back then like people were like
just use shotgun you sniper it's like no
I can put it down pretty well with this
like yeah like and if I don't put them
down I'll just swap to last word and she
go tap tap and then they're done or like
tap tap turned vous pow because
somebody's thinking they're just gonna
be able to sneak up on you they're
trying to be cute yeah and so it's it's
a fun it's a fun loadout and even then
like I was kind of sad that last word
gotten neutered to the point that it is
now even though it's it's good for
controllers oh yeah for controllers it's
still it's still very viable in PC it's
not usable anymore I'm still I'm still
out here I'm still yeah I'm telling
y'all right now if y'all using this with
last word I got y'all hipfire it it is
better than it was before
it is beast yet last word is what about
counters that is definitely a strong
count and I'm with McFly like I'm the
same way it's just that I get you know
say you see people everyone use the same
thing so it's like now I don't want to
do that I want to I got a go against I
gotta find something it just took me a
while so I'm like man this thing's beat
this did like all of my top guns are
like we're just knocking out the product
so until you wanna settle in but yeah I
completely yeah and so it it's okay but
it um I still think though like you can
be rewarded for not giving in to the
meta in the sense that like you feel you
shouldn't feel like you have to use hard
light there are still guns in the game
that can go toe to toe a lot of it just
comes down to how are you playing is
your
good did you just are you actually just
straight-up losing because this gun is
stronger or are you just making bad
choices because there's so many things
that happen within a PvP game you know
cuz there could be many things out of
your control like connection
we don't have dedicated servers so that
that could always be an issue like I was
around that corner how did he shoot me
in the butt when he's up here it's like
connectivity but there are ways to
outplay people and so like even people
that are older like me like I may not be
able to when I say older like I'm in my
30s but not being able to like I may not
be as cracked out as like a 18 year old
who can really beat you know just frying
and putting people down but I have a lot
of shooter experience I have more years
of experience and so I can use that to
my advantage and I can play chess while
he tries to play checkers again yeah so
if I want to say okay cool I want to get
him to come make a bad choice so I'm
gonna start retreating and pulling him
back and you know pulling like an art of
war style choice and like hey I want you
to come to me and fight me in here I'm
not coming to you and so doing things
like that are ways to you know I
wouldn't say like rise above the meta
but it there's there's different ways
that you can choose to fight you just
you don't have to just rush in there and
I know like because with trials and
elimination you know so many people have
been playing you know respawn style game
modes you know with control and even
like comp like survivals a respawn mode
you know this one is like when you're
down you're down and so you have to you
have to play different long after yeah I
agree with that mentality - what are my
best counters but the eight right now is
on my man that decide on last hole Oh
got me a feeding frenzy I believe on
what it is the role what Dad did yeah
it's really beast and I can literally
backpedal when they're very aggressive
and really really slow down the Apes
with that look the Mayan banners and
stuff like that but um yeah man I agree
man it's all about playstyle adjusting
doing things to try to encounter certain
things would agree with that
the tactical
yeah yeah rational awareness doesn't
wonders when you guys are going as you
said just like play a fight like you
know somebody's crouching around the
corner you see that little like flash of
the radar you like I'm not going around
that corner or if you do you're like
that was dumb like yeah or you come to
you yeah you're like a few decisions for
sure yeah and like I'm I'm still like
you know running a Titan again like
shoulder charge just feels good man like
when you actually like connect ah oh man
it's one of those things like I love I
forget the guys name but he's got a big
mustache and he's always in the vital
yes and there's a lot of like vocal
sound effects I love this man yes I
really hope I get to meet him someday
and just give him a hug because like you
are such a sound guy and I love it
and but like that's how I feel though
about shoulder charges you know when
you're able to round that corner and
just Foom and you just put him down like
it feels good but it does put me in
positions where I'm trying to go for
that shoulder charge and when I get put
down because I'm aping I know that's my
fault I don't get pissed I'm like I made
a stupid choice because I either thought
a they were closer or I was just kidding
I was you know bloodthirsty you know I
was just seeing the red I was like I'm
gonna get booed it's like this boy needs
to taste my knees charging with my
social distancing is important and to
getting used to the other lock on
distance yeah I found myself
shortchanging like a little bit yeah
have the muscle memory in that's all as
a walk that's all I shoot were locks
were just fine someone they go out woman
like playing warlock for a while that
melee was still fine they didn't need
the increased speed because they're the
the power on it was so good and the
distance was good yeah I have an issue
with it but but we all have to agree
soup and overhead Oh handheld over it
totally 40% shield from the controversal
that was crazy
so yeah bust and as well as data that
what I'd mask
deal with that happened even as its
heightened I'm happy it's gone because
just when you're facing like God there
it is yeah like I'm just it's all sodium
out of handsome exotic
I'm not I I I'm definitely the same
campus you know form over function
sometimes away what don't you like about
[Music]
it looks ugly man like it's almost a
horror movie slash sci-fi and like a
futuristic horror movie mask it's like
it's if I built
yeah if I made my aesthetic more mad
max-style then maybe it could work but
it I don't know man it just I like to
see my Titan is like a space night and
so like I try to make him look like I
don't know this just unit and this just
it makes him look like he's putting on
like a mask there's something walking
around like I mean if you like if you
just look at you like that
no I was gonna say like a Titan I
picture and they nailed it to like the
saint-14 last season seasonal armor
mm-hmm that's a friggin Titan like the
like Oh totally yeah so it's like been
when you have this lake crazy mesh
one-eyed funky yeah yeah that would not
dislike glorious great and that's the
same thing with like verities brow or
some of those like bone ones I'm like
where do you fit in oh my I have no
fashion in this game by the way I get
called out on Twitter alright yeah yeah
there's a guy that's he's made some
pretty good-looking Titans and
characters he's a guy from reso I think
it's Lego like Lego flash or something
like that I remember he put out a Titan
that had AI think it's like blood
something it's like one of the shaders
you can get that's mostly black that has
some red accents to it but if you don't
have a dead orbit shader this is like a
consolation yeah it's a back up dead
orbit shader pretty much with red but he
had something down low it was like a
dreaming city ever verse air legs and
it's like you know what that looks kind
of cool it had like a glassy tone to it
but it like was busted because it was
like abnormally a bone texture but the
way this shader applied to it it made it
shiny it's like okay that actually is
that's a good look so there's ways to
you know make things fit like that's one
of things I was happy that we can now
like ISO shader perlite
and so we can try to like work our way
into making our own different pieces so
much individual completely that's one of
the most underrated changes we have that
ability oh yeah surviving hard life and
then now under my sorrows catalyst so
I'm working on a channel
I got buys good I got visor heart like
what then guys that's why that's my
panic button in traffic things go wrong
then I'm got your heart lights yeah in
case of emergency break glass catalyst
hard like we've there you don't say I
don't want to admit I don't want to I
don't want to get weak and it's listed s
do I'm trying to focus on what you say
but like do these other things get these
other guns going yeah bird but also play
your way to that that's what makes
destiny great you you can indeed play
your way to a degree it just may mean
you have to alter like your play style a
little bit or like you maybe need to you
know educate yourself a little bit or
just honestly be open to criticizing
yourself an admitting you made a mistake
absolutely yeah it's okay to say you
know what I charged my shot was off like
I'll even say to my own chat like if I
miss a snipe I'm like you know what I
was bottom left I wasn't on his head you
know I wish I was off right I shot too
soon or I don't even know why I took
that shot I just took it but you know
that's the great prophet Gretzky once
said you miss 100% of the shots you
don't take
you don't think yeah sometimes you gotta
take a shot you might hit that's why
beloved is so nice you can actually take
as many shots as you can don't take too
many so that works out pretty well
oh yeah revoke her sorry that was yeah
let's say beloved wait hold on what
world you get be like secret yeah I got
that secret you know bungee hook-up roll
hold on someone called deej we got I
guess I got yeah I got the connection to
look over here it's whatever in sandbox
changes that II ends up bringing up on
the last word they literally get fax
right over the loop and then the next
maybe week or two we'll get a new
directors cuts plating the new did
directional change and philosophy change
and he gets what he wants man man
ghostwriter for Bungie confirmed you
heard
here first now that whole joke started
because before the director's cut
recently came out the Friday before it
dropped on like Tuesday morning or
something I had literally mentioned to
him about the Sun setting with no like
idea at all and then like Tuesday it
comes out and he was like dude dude you
looking like the smartest guy in the
room it worked well for once yeah it
worked pretty well for once but not yes
Sun setting is a good thing
it happens in Wow it's you need to you
need to keep the player base hungry you
need to keep us chasing loot things need
to cycle out I mean it happens even in
freaking hearthstone like come on like
you need a reason for people to come
back man we went we've gone down this
road multiple times I have taken it to
an extreme one side and he is to the
other and we've had some Duke outs
it seems so it seems like you're pretty
much okay with what Luke said nine about
weapon he's getting cycled out yep yeah
absolutely I think it's a good thing now
I I do I can see reasons that it could
maybe pissed some people off so I I
think it's really cool that I'm lucky
that I've got other people like in my
family that play destiny my
father-in-law you know who's a
grandfather plays destiny still and
loves it but he would be heat so I get
honestly he'll come and ask me questions
all the time about the game because he
knows I play it he knows I streams it
that I stream it and so I do get to
honestly see someone's perspective
that's drastically different than mine
and when some of his guns now he doesn't
really understand the idea of sun
setting but seeing the weapons that he's
still using because he likes them and
knowing that you know those can get
taken away from him I can see someone
who doesn't play nearly as much but
still enjoys the game I can see that
bringing a lot of frustration but at the
same time you know there you have to
make a choice whether you're going to
try to keep certain people happy and
it's gonna piss off another group and
vice versa and so a big philosophy idea
that I've heard for
from gamedev stuff I can't remember if I
heard it from can't remember honestly
can't remember the source but this is
kind of me paraphrasing it sometimes
need to protect the player from
themselves
and to make sure you've ensured the fun
and you keep the game engaging and so if
that means making sure that you can't
always lean on recluse in PvP and even
PvE
to ensure that the endgame experience is
still like not easy mode that's
something that you have to do and you
know the player may get mad at you
because you're basically taking the kids
toy away but you're doing it because you
know what I know when I take this from
you you're gonna be put in a position
where your next raid or your next big
endgame activity is going to be that
much more enjoyable and it's one of
those things they have to look out for
the best interest of us as the players
in the long term and that's definitely
in the responsibility quart of Bungie
and I think that's what they're trying
to do yellow yellow glowing ones so okay
hit me hit me hit me I'm ready to leave
think of the caffeine's hitting I was
like mid stride so so the other side is
do you think this should ever hit
exotics uh honestly I don't know how you
would approach it with exotics because
they're it's so genius you know now you
save yourself because the thing is like
with exotics summer quest based and some
are not and it's so that that on it that
honestly just alone makes exotic tuning
and Sun setting even bigger of an issue
and I can understand why they didn't do
it yet because you have things like
whisper you know something that's super
good and is ease you know things that
are but their quest based and you have
to do something to go get it so it is
attainable and they're not taking it
away so like guns like those probably
won't go away if if the Sun setting
begins quest ones will probably stay
right because someone that's coming in
you want to you don't want to close off
things that they could do you mean
acquisition in in someone putting all
time investment for for a catch up on
previous episodes yes
but anyway so but you need to but at the
same time two things do need to rotate
out I mean look at wow you know it's one
of the most successful largely played
games in the world it's still one of the
biggest played games in the world as far
as like active player base goes you
can't deny that it's a juggernaut and
they still cycle things out like raid
armor cycles out and a new expansion
drops it goes on first-person shooter
game where guns are the actual
acquisition there's weapons in WoW
there's weapons in WoW and those even
those eventually get cycled out too it's
like you can't make this better or you
can only make it better so many times
and so maybe that could be a way of
limiting it nah never mind throw that
out that's a stupid thought but I do
think you do need to make you have it
I'm going back to what I said before
sometimes you need to protect the player
from themselves and you need to
incentivize them to keep going into
dipping into the new stuff and grinding
the gear to play a game that is grindy
it's a looot game guys we all know what
we're getting into and we boot up
destiny unless it's someone that's
totally taking it on a whim and just
downloading d2 for free on Steam or
playing xbox
like for them I'll give them a pass but
people that have been in it for a while
that know what the game is it's a looot
game you know you're here to go get
stuff you're here to get shiny loot
that's what you're about and also maybe
go you know click heads in crucible but
you need to make sure that that that
wheel keeps turning and sometimes you
need to you know kick that kid out the
door and make sure like hey you know you
know go swim here we're in the deep end
get to the other side good luck exactly
and you know one of those things do like
it may piss you off and say uh but I did
all these things but it's like yeah but
there's these cooler things on that
other side of the pool that is gonna be
real fun trust me swim so being that
back you say buy point get in here they
said oh I literally agree with every big
you're saying as far as legendary I
think that is a valid point I think that
Aaron at the end of it at the end of the
day the loop will get saturated you know
I'm saying it and I feel that totally
yeah it is now yeah it's open
have to do it my only argument was
literally what you also agree with me in
terms of exotics because of the
acquisition the time investment to get
them and then my argument for keeping
exactly where you are is that they
represent such a small percentage of the
overall new pool and I'm saying so that
that's why I say okay
those can stay and then my argument that
had happened was that if there was going
to be a sunsetting of exotics then my
feeling request based stuff for
acquisition stuff you know things like
whisper things like um Albert I'm you
know zero-hour these cars for tourism
last word ace right there you go so Mike
these are all tied in my thing is you
know destiny at its core the system's
itself you know three to five years we
kind of get to a point where we're
maxing out real estate we're maxing them
out you know as far as the the systems
and things that they can do in the game
so at that point I feel we need a new
game and I think these are band-aid
stopgap stopgap measures to kind of hold
us down because we all know since
leaving Activision they're not ready to
go to definitely right right now so I
think this these are kind of stop guys
okay let's do some weapon retirement
just do some other things and then
hopefully when d3 comes then you can
pick by exotics away or do whatever you
want to do at that point that was my
only lock but that was literally just of
it
the reality is I actually am in
agreement with what you're saying scary
stuff and exact stuff so we actually
only same page yeah yeah no I think we
are in the same page - and then even
then like honestly just because of the
nature of exotics and what they can
bring to your play style and like
especially with armor - like things they
can even like affect your neutral game
like I love dune marchers for a Titan
because I get that extra movement speed
like I can now be as fast as a hunter in
terms of my sprint speed that's chain
that's game-changing and in terms of
your neutral game and then you know or
you get that second dodge as a hunter
you know there's there's different
things that you know are good to have
because you're making a choice whether
it's gonna enhance my ability or it's
gonna give me an extra of something else
ability or things like that like
those need to stay in the game because
that it gives you as a player agency to
affect what you're trying to do like
what your role is or what you just enjoy
doing like if I like punching things
give me my synthesis let's go boxing
it's you know there's there's reasons
for certain things and then that leads
into builds which I know destiny is what
they're trying to encourage that more
you know with build and the mod system
which is still it's getting there and I
appreciate what they're trying to do but
I do agree to Lord is that you're
getting to a point where we are starting
to max out what the game is currently
with destiny to you know I do think the
next thing is probably something like
whatever is destiny 3 or destiny 3.0
which to me fingers crossed from my
mouth to Luke Smith's ears is a inner
like a connected player base much like
Khan's where everybody plays together
with the new systems which i think is
very likely future I would kill for six
play of roles oh sure but honestly just
being able to play with different people
but also I think but having that extra
Hardware capability I think the games
themselves because that's why we see
we're seeing things cycled out you know
like there's just there's not space
anymore without making the game insanely
large and even then like you know that's
a lot of just data just squeezed into
like a downloadable package you know and
there comes to you know you hit a push
poll moment where you know what are you
trying to do kill someone's hard drive
or give them a good experience that
rotates yeah and you know I know that
they're moving and marching to that
direction and so I anticipate that being
a thing is that will eventually have
everything together but but yeah back to
sunsetting exotics though like I don't
think it's going to be if it happens I
don't know if we'll see it this year I
don't know if we'll see it before
September absolutely not one question
about exotics was this this is the one
thing I asked him took me like 10
minutes to get a flat answer but I did
finally get one so and this is the
hypothetical because we're talking about
the saturation of destiny and I gave
that little caveat to it but
take take the whiteboard for example
that you saw in the vitac while ago year
four or five six seven say destiny to
some how does they don't like make a 3.0
and blow up the tower and start
completely over they can see they won't
do that again bit thank you thank you
thick big I'm not saying I won't do that
again I don't think they'll blow it up
but I actually wonder if like the
saint-14 mission where like we die or
whatever no I don't think they'll do
that I think it'll be truly gated like
you know when when Burning Crusade first
dropped in Wow you know the first big
expansion for the game it's like all
this stuff yeah you could stay level 60
but as you level up this stuff stay 60
so everything you're getting your blues
are now replacing your you know your
purples right out of the gate you know
yeah so I think that's just what's gonna
so like much facial question was like
say the game does last say Dustin you to
does keep going and they do a sort of
Destiny to 3.0 or 4.0 or however this
thing goes say it is like a mere six of
whatever this whole franchise is and my
question was should you still be able to
take whisper into the newest raid and
have it still be effective how long I
was like I was trying to like take an
extreme level of if it lasts and we're
still in this world should like the year
one exotic quest weapon still be
infusible up to the newest the highest
light level he's like on my screen he's
right in the middle in what we were just
saying that we don't know you know cuz
it's the way that whisper is honestly I
think a unique one to use this example
for because it's something you have to
do a specific activity to obtain this
isn't something you can get from xur
it's not an rng drop you have to do
something to get it so I don't think
that's a fair comparison but because of
what it is it's a heavy yeah but man I
don't know and here's the I don't him
part of me says yeah part of me says no
because I mean if I say no then what is
in the game that is comparable that
makes that I could go get you know if
there's something that is a strong heavy
in its place that is very good for PvE
specifically for boss fighting because
that's what whisper is good for his
bosses it's not a PvP
sniper no or it's not intended to be in
terms of its perk set unless you're just
acing people but even then like you're
it's such a honking hulking thing your
abs beat is terrible it's not it's not
if your heart scoped pretty bad yeah
exactly and so if there is something
that is comparable to my damage output
then then I would say yes as long as
there's something that's available or at
least there's maybe there's a thing
that's designed with the new raid that
snipers really aren't viable at all or
it's maybe not considered optimal or
like the design is more like we're
building this to be more of like a
shotgun style boss like this is rath
we're like you can get on top of the
boss just oh yeah sure and maybe this
boss doesn't have a stop mechanic and
things like that so I think I would say
yes
as long as there is design to keep it
engaging to where I'm not gonna be like
man if I only had whisper you know as
long as you don't have that remorse feel
and there's other way other things that
have been designed in what's coming I
think it could work but there needs to
be an overall design plan before you
this man there's the scene that was some
Bungie peahi just day right like it's
genuinely how I feel it's one of those
things like I think it can be done but
you got to do it appropriately and I
don't and I'm not even claiming that
that's even the best answer but that's
just like if they can hear on the spot I
think that's something to at least
consider you know if you're gonna be Sun
setting and exotic you need to make sure
when you do that that there are ways to
make sure that the game is still fun
there's ways to still there's things
that I can chase they can replace it or
even be more fun based on the mechanics
and what's going on and you can still do
things like patrols yeah whip it out go
have some fun or if you're running
classic stuff go do it but when it comes
to like you know the current endgame
thingamajig you know if it's not in my
arsenal of what I can use then I must
have other things that I can get that
will still make me
boss when make me a killing machine you
know like a demigod killing machine you
know you need to make sure that you're
still empowering the player if you're
removing a power but if you take is
something the way that's worth oh yeah
like hey you know you worked really hard
for this cool but guess what there's a
thing right over there keep working for
it I guarantee you you're probably gonna
love it it's all I need to know that's
all I need no cyber nari whose meaning
he was sitting on this one for us he was
just saying uh courtesy we talked about
bob pvp said what weapon loadout do the
three of you go for fun right now in PvE
what's your fun loadout I don't know for
me I don't know if I have a fun loadout
mostly because I'm usually working on
bounties no no I'm usually literally
like I have weapons so many times the
season because they're repeatable
bounders are just like use these weapons
I'm like alright so what do I need to do
I need to like I need a void bow a hand
cannon and an art machine urn and going
how much did I get this - double dip I
need the ark and autos part lights
coming out let's go yes so like that's
this season probably has been the most
versatile use just because I haven't
been doing that much rating I've been
doing a lot of bounties and public
events and butchers and stuff like that
so I honestly haven't don't have a great
answer for that one right now because
I've shifted daily pretty much picking
up the repeatable Ziff not every hour
depending on what I'm working on so know
that you stay within the mix of it what
about when you're doing your own laughs
now I shouldn't say that cuz I know
you're gonna go to you the ol reliables
when you do you like your night falls
and your legendary lost sectors though
what about what you do is serif all you
do still doing your bounties and you're
still doing the bad news like if I'm
doing if I'm doing seraphim yeah a bit
overplay yeah I'm working on time
efficient yeah literally everything's
kind of stalking those until I know I've
got like the next 3000 which I'm almost
there for the next bunker to login and
turn that one over can be done right
it's been a weird season I mean yeah I
have my you know favourites but even
just something like when we got fourth
horseman I was like oh if you actually
run with a party and there'd be like hey
you once topple him
and then I do a sword I will say swords
okay I'll give you that
yes so let's go away this isn't I have
used more than I ever have because you
got the reserves perk you've got the
captain overloads between all the lost
sectors and stuff no I've been using a
crap but a swords I heard you use what
sword it was a sword so from what I've
got I gotta remember the name the
biggest ones I like though are the ones
cuz I've got like tireless or assassin's
blade on them so if I do the lots of
single below attacks why do I get the
ammo back FL yes that's a lot of what
I've been using because I've got like
tireless blade and then assassin's blade
for like sword kills me move faster and
then relentless strikes so anything with
those three and I guess it's all just a
steel Sybil it's just that one that I
keep getting from that the crucible
would I think it is but yes I've got a
couple of those and then I probably
don't I probably have a couple other
ones I could try but mostly just like
yeah just I love the looping animation
on the sword infinite strike is just
because if there's like 20 guys always
like dudududududududu and I just I don't
run out I would have more of this this
is the type of fee that I like to get
when I don't hear about that go figure
it I've heared about you I get a lot of
crap this is what I'm talking about this
is beautiful swords have been
surprisingly a lot of fun for I've
soloed all the lost sectors so far in
each of them even if it's unstoppable
hit him with a hand cannon go in there
swipe swipe swipe swipe swipe if he
wakes up back the hell out
get that up again oh stop Ola hand
cannon shot and do it again so like it's
kind of determinate the top two are
typically determined on what I'm working
on is it bounties is it unstoppable as a
barrier is it overload but swords I even
try like grenade launchers or machine
nothing holds up because everything is
built close anyway right now fairly
chair reasonably so then if I can get a
sword in there the only thing I can tell
you I absolutely cannot stand barrier
servitors haynam - no I'm not not
digging those right now they are
annoying because they hit you that hard
then they just they don't have a
cool-down on there they just shield
indefinitely I'm like do you not like
run out of gas overheat your little
shield servo pack on your bat somethin
like I need a window I need a window
somewhere in there to take out the other
enemies cuz otherwise I have like in a
legendary lost sector that was in power
level and there's six vandals shooting
crap at me and they're all tracking
bullets I'm like and I can't even hurt
him I'm like at some point this so I
have to like try and weasel up be like
okay look at me look at me don't kill me
and try and slowly pull one down the
stairs and kill him okay got you out of
line of sight come up again pull another
guy I have two line of sight these guys
like one at a time as opposed to
eventually like getting a cool-down on
just some normal ability so but no
swords are awesome can't stand barrier
servitors that's that's my general
feeling on ppm oh yeah I got a slaver
I got a home shout the Cyberman it's a
good question um right now
same thing swords with you I got the
black rubbery one I believe strikers
something same thing tireless blade I
got that that uh that perp that like you
said the overload perk so basically once
I get that champion down I'm bum-rushing
them with the sword they they have they
don't stand a chance but you do your
quick swag for your uppercut you're out
of it I got that surprisingly hard light
if you ve I've been loving it man just
the versatility I'm saying justify yeah
it's good burn yeah yeah you got the
burn I got my sword up close I got my
heart light and I'm I told you it's this
I pulled it out the vault so since I did
what is it a barrier for an arm side
arms I believe it is yet pillager I've
been doing pillager though that little
what your core so I feel like I got all
my ranges you know when they're up close
I got I got pillager and then I got the
UH the barrier to knock that stuff down
I got my heart light from distance with
the birds and then the sword for the
oval oh guys knock them out and then the
build right now as I went back to Arc
and I got a shout out I believe era put
me on to this build on or off diversity
but um he's basically it's it's a it's a
class item perk
that every time you use any arc either
super melee you drop some war myself
yeah
so the National is using the yeah I'm
using the war mine cell mods now so that
the blast radius is bigger that it does
burn damage then I got another one
that's a chest armor one that it also
provides overload disruption or whatever
this thing is powerful like I get
excited when that war mine things I
can't wait to shoot it cuz I'm like
who's around who's around we ready yes
it is amazing and the last thing with
this order I think I also have a
surrounded perk on my own sword I've
been a fun man it's been a really fun
aggressive kind of build and he be proud
of it taking a page out of your book man
I sold my first one man nice I've been
loving this bill really yeah when you
get to light level those aren't quite at
those aren't really that bad
i underleveled myself there's some
issues but yeah if you go in it like
thousand thousand five I mean yeah you
got to play kind of smart but they're
really not that bad of like 10 minutes
or so usually pretty good what about you
geez I'm kind of the same way with II
like if if I'm working on bounties I try
to optimize on that but for the most
part I really liked using Sun shot just
because Oh collateral is just far like
anything with like you know Firefly and
then adding the you know the Dragonfly
just that's just fun it's just fun to
see or like the solar explosions camp
drop war mine cells to there's one of
the mods I think can do that now yeah
and besides also saying it works with
ace as well which is dope so that's good
to know because I love ace ace was still
like my one of my favorite guns and so I
want to see 150 rpms come back in
crucible because I just oh they're good
well Sun shots 150 rpms yeah so it's
quickly yeah I just I want ace to come
back always because we asked 140 right
yeah I would love a stand back yeah and
so I just use my austere again too but
yeah but as far as like PvE though like
I still love hammerhead
a legendary cuz I just I've got a
rampage feeding frenzy off so jealousy
yeah and so like that's my favorite like
LMG and even though like I have 21
delirium like I only use it if it's a
narc one cuz yeah it's fun but just
hammer head just is like like you just
feel like it's the forged weapons I
honestly would probably vote that group
as probably my favorite feel and sound
like Tatara gays it's it reminds me of
like the Barrett 50 Cal in real life it
is just like it's just the way it sounds
yeah and then ringing yeah I'm firing
that one I pulled that one out for solar
Auto Riesling ghillie our got a ghillie
or there's no way to farm that
specifically there's no it's just like
go kill the saboteur one of 12 what your
farm last furnace
every time I kill yard earlier yeah have
to do something that's a little bit
wonky yeah that's more of a slot machine
Bowl but yeah but yeah and then even
though trying to think like other
weapons that I use for PvE we're close I
still use just because it's still even
though it's not as strong it's still so
wrong
yeah especially if it's any kind of void
burn too it's just it's it's a great
thing to pair with anything else in your
loadout and then I did use Izzy's for a
long time I just need to spend the
enhancement stuff to get just to infuse
whisper backup that's still been stuck
in my vault
I just cuz I haven't been raiding really
recently I've been trying to get the
unbroken title and so I just I just got
to get one more comp Legend spot and so
once I kind of get that done I'll be
switching hard back to PvE so I've been
more so like really focusing on my PvP
loadouts but shotguns are still fun to
like you know paradox is still enjoyable
yeah but anything that makes stuff go
boom like if it has Firefly or dragon
fly like I got that stuff makes me happy
yeah that's especially like on drags
like if it's a raw that's a power
fantasy that I can get behind
they always do so with it so I feel like
there was one topic when it came to so
we got kind of PvE and PvP II kind of
got a feel for weapons and uses and
stuff like that but there was a
discussion we hadn't quite gotten to yet
it was the light level and trials and I
knew you'd been kind of sitting about it
so I wanted to kind of let you captain
get a chance to talk about this one
especially with like your experience
being busy having three days a week to
play for just like a set number of hours
because you have well actual real life
responsibilities unlike some of the
people live in the game imagine owners
got boomer problems so and it's just one
of those cuz even for like me I'm
actually decently higher now so it's
like I just wanted to get your feel on
trials its current status how you been
feeling and just your thoughts on just
the whole situation with everything with
trials right now
sure overall just like I just want to
preface this at the top like I even when
trials was even in the discussion of
like should it come back you know is it
in a position to come back I'm still in
the camp that it's better to get it in
here and knowing that there's still
things that are broken and even though
it may like shine a magnifying glass on
things that need to be tweaked and
adjusted there still needs to be an
endgame PvP activity that is something
that you can do on a weekly basis it
just needs to be a thing if something
that's been missing for so long there
was a core part of the d1 experience and
it needed to come back regardless
whether it was ready or not it just
needed to be here so now that it's here
and we're in it now we get to live that
that timeline so like you said you know
someone like me that you know I work you
know 50 hours a week plus you know I can
only play three nights a week because
you know I still spend time with my
family and things like that and things
to do around the house so I I destiny
wise I get to put it in 1215 hours a
week somewhere in there I'm not I just
now I'm getting to be about nine ninety
like the mid-1990s to keep you know
being transparent and like my season
rank is like almost in the 30s so yeah
people break all casual it's like you
don't shut up I'm still enjoy the game
we're like fifteen days into the season
though people are like oh that's been
why are you not maxed up you're like I'm
two weeks into a 12-week season yeah
it's like dude there's like 80 days left
to go or something there 70 days like
chill out like this
this is a supposed to be a long grind
for the average player so for my trials
experience so far I expected to get
slapped in the first week and I did
because I was like 970 and I was
encountering people in a thousand I was
getting dunked with mountaintop like I
had never been so fearful of mountaintop
in my life there's a thousand I'm like
well shoot dude if he just even hits the
ground near me I'm done yeah there's
nothing I can do about that and so it
was a bit frustrating because I'm like I
know I can beat these guys because I
would go late comp and I would just
wreck but it's like I know my gun skill
is here to compete I know I can do it I
can win my 1/v ones I can sometimes pull
a 2 or a 3 V 1 I can do it but they do
have an advantage because they either
they just were able to contribute more
time than I could and I also didn't
bounty stack I didn't do that I just I
approached the seasoned fresh you know I
made that choice to I could have been it
cuz I've done that before with other
DLCs from destiny one and even D 2 and
it's like ah I just want to just play
the game you know I'm not I'm you know
I'm not trying to you know like ease in
a different position you know he's got
to make content about things that are
happening with the game and other people
that are in that situation too they need
to get to the end so they can discuss
the things at the end quicker and sooner
because they got to be first totally get
that I'm not in that position and I'm
not that kind of guy and so I'm just
here to enjoy it so from from a trials
perspective the light level thing is a
bit frustrating but at the same time I
am happy that it's there and it should
be there because there needs to be
something to strive for because you know
what it's doing for me is yeah I'm
frustrated but it's making me think
alright I need to make sure I'm
dedicating time to go do my pinnacles I
need to go get powerful drops I am now
intentionally saying alright
it's reset I'm gonna go do my three
strikes that's a powerful drop I'm gonna
get my bounties done for Zavala that's
another one I'm gonna I will get my ones
from shacks just because I'm playing
ranked so I save that for later when I'm
ready to pivot Friday and Monday to be
all go because I say that day's so
Wednesday is like now my PvE day so it's
like I'm gonna do anything I can do PvE
whether it's my flash points or strikes
or whatever
or the the bunkers do gambit I mean
struggling to do game yeah yeah like
once honestly break Nick and dredgen
broke gambit for me so much gambit so
much gambit but I did like game but at
the time don't get me wrong like I
remember playing at Guardian con for the
first time I was like this modes dope
this modes fun it's just out of them
I've because I've played so much of it
it's like I kind of just want time away
yeah so and that's not a knock on the
mode that's just because I had to play
so much to talk to uh just to get these
a couple things but trials though as a
whole with the power advantage yeah it
sucks it can really really suck because
you really like even now like I'm going
in and someone's 1,000 and I'm in the
1980s I'm like sweet he already has a
major advantage on me and so does his
team especially if they team child like
I'm in deep deep trouble and I've
shoulder charged guys and with the solar
subclass that applies a burn and a heavy
hit and they tank it yes and they don't
die and I'm like okay like my one hit
kill ability that I have knowing that I
can punish him because I caught him
looking down a hallway at my teammate
and I can drop him right now
is able to survive turn and burn me and
he survives the burn that I put on him
so it's like okay and is that because
it's a hundred percent because of power
my damage dealt and his receive are
making it to where he's not gonna die
right so it feeds back in where it's
like all right I need to go grind PvE
but cuz it but it gives me something to
strive for you know and it's like
alright if I want to be able to do
better in trials I do need to grind some
PvE I need to level oh so it's it's
frustrating from a competitive sense
because you're like I'm it's a weird
pill to swallow saying I'm not losing
because I'm bad right I'm losing because
this person played more or got better
drops than I did at the time so that
it's a weird position to be in but at
the same time where it's like if he if
it's truly because he's putting time in
to get to get that gear to get his level
up I can't be mad at that because I know
I can't put in the same time as him
and so like all right fine that if
that's why I'm losing that's okay and I
know that I can accept that and so yeah
that's how I feel about it
cool I also wanted to ask for both of
you guys as well with kind of this thing
running around I see it on Twitter saw
different things discussing it over the
weekends everybody was basically farming
three wins four tokens
once they ran into that a lot yeah
so you're facing and yeah so this is
what it this is the next topic for
trials and this is the big one that's
going on like once the weapon is in your
loophole once you've acquired it then
your tokens can let you get drops on the
weapon right and then people are just
farming tokens by getting to three in
row resetting over and over so like the
flawless and all that stuff so you needs
to be adjusted daddy that you yeah so I
was like I'll go for it if you want to
dive in or anything abyss is what I said
um yeah I mean it that's literally what
my issue is I was gonna really backtrack
real quick same say I'm in the same boat
as you
um McFly in the sense of the whole the
power thing again initially I struggled
with it but at you know I do
[Music]
fundamentally like it it's there I just
I felt the artefact showed the disparity
and then once it went away and then it
was you know just bow level you know
saying it was a little it was a little
bit more tolerable yeah you know it
wasn't as that's crazy
now to this I agree this is the problem
because what's happening now with this
whole three wins barrier is that you're
getting the sweatiest matches from one
to three like am i at least my
experience anecdotal but it's it's it's
insane because you're getting top guy
I'm like to work I say I play five
matches trials you know I'm seeing guys
with lighthouse emblems in round one and
I'm like you don't match one and I'm
just like man like this is this is gonna
be sweaty and they've got to make an
adjustment because that right there that
just that whole farming bit I just don't
like I don't like the way it disrupts as
far as the balance as far as when you're
facing on your card and they need to
take that away
and then the other issue is um you know
I still have an issue with the lack of a
depth weapon you know I'm saying I feel
that at the hydrants coming later I hope
so because at the very minimum I feel
that new perk what is it celerity or
whatever it's cool yeah that should be
an inch it should be intrinsic that
should be a you know a second thing it
should be a flawless perk a flawless
weapon perk just like it wasn't before
yeah very easy it's not my aunt a
celerity I'm like damn that should just
be a thing I mean again and then look at
what it what the scenario is you're at a
disadvantage for it to proc right so
yeah like come all in a way it's wasting
a slot until your last exactly it's
literally a waste of a slot in a sense
so I feel they should really revisit
this a DEP thing III again I said it
last last matter is that I think Bungie
sometimes has been very overly cautious
with rewarding the the best of the best
right sure that this at the same time
this is a pinnacle activity this is this
is an achievement right you want people
to strive for these things and I think
by making the loop the same that it's
not it's taken away from that desire to
get better to do to do these things you
want to have that feeling when you see
someone with a weapon that's unique you
want to cover that man what do I have to
do to get to acquire that and I missed
that aspect from d1 you're a resident d2
it seems every week or so every 12 we're
getting something pulled away we're
getting this some hard activity some
high level chase pinnacle weapon that
may have some buff or extra perk you
know take it away so dad that's my main
issue right now could be a little nicer
with the you know maybe a golf ball here
or near a couple of sending shots here
and there sure shower them a little bit
with those low resources yeah something
I would like to see is like a wait I
don't even know how you even implement
this cuz this would be like a serious
back-end thing but if somebody has gone
flawless that week you somehow put like
a marker
on their account that says okay this
person has gone flawless this week so
they've already they've shown that
they're able whether they were carry it
or not the fact that they've made it all
the way they should not be facing people
in their first game or they're working
on their first card or they are they
should be like there should be like a
threshold like okay now you're only
gonna be fighting people that are on
their own win 5 and higher because guess
what you were just playing higher end so
you shouldn't even be in the matchmaking
pool for people that are you know just
getting in on their first card now I do
understand that this kind of can go into
people doing account recoveries or some
other nefarious things there's only so
much you could do to fight that until
you get hard evidence and stuff but even
then like how do you enforce that well
it's so more focusing on like just what
it is you know apples to apples like if
somebody is actually doing their first
card I if I'm doing Game one Friday for
me I should not be fighting you know
someone who is already gone flawless and
this now token forming shouldn't see
Osiris eyes in you bana when we go well
that's fine if they've gotten flawless a
week prior that's good at this point
we've had 2 full weeks there's more
people that have gone all the way so
there's there's chances you're gonna
encounter people with trials armour and
weapons and emblems and stuff so if
you're in your first card though you
should be going against people that are
you know still either a working on their
first card and be right around the same
win number as you yeah that's that's
supposed to be the intended matchmaking
or it should be that should be the
desire and so I think that could be a
way to help fight it a little bit is if
your token farming well guess what
you're still going to be going against
people that are harder so yeah you could
still farm that's fine if you want to do
that if you want to go sit and grind a
loss sector for the next 12 hours to
level up your pass more power to you if
that's your level of fun and that's what
you want to do fine I think and that's
the thing like I don't think tokens are
a problem I don't because you need to
look at it from a perspective of someone
I I'm going back to my father-in-law
here someone who isn't good at PvP and
will definitely be you know he'll be
willing to admit that I'm not throwing
him under the bus but someone who also
can't play that much but you're giving
them a chance to get loot
yep by just participating in it it's
like even me like my first week like I
didn't get flawless but I was still able
to put tokens in to get some stuff so
like I still had a chance to pull that
machine to at least come away with
something or get like a roll or whatever
so I think that still needs to be in
there because you need to reward the
player for their time because if they
just straight up can't do it you need to
make sure that they're getting a chance
to do it because and that I think that's
how they're riding that middle ground
which you know we sometimes we're like
you're doing it too much it's like well
we don't want to you know spit in the
same people that are you know the
majority of the playerbase you know
destiny has a very vocal minority very
vocal we are very loud really just
gamers in general we are loud but we're
able to reach them like as either
streamers or content creators or people
on Twitter or reddit there's ways to get
in front of the dev for those that are
really motivated enough to do so but the
majority of the people that like the
vast like the biggest population of the
game don't even do it they don't watch
twitch they don't you tube videos
they're not on Reddit they're not on
Twitter but that's that's the big base
so it's one of those things where you
can't get rid of it but there needs to
be a way to separate or at least like
maybe reroute their matchmaking to where
they're not hitting people that are just
starting their very first card and
haven't gotten flawless yet because
that's that's our in the experience ya
know I mean that sound yes I'm gonna
flag either character or account however
you do it like max of three times that
you're gonna get like that easier
run-through on per character and then
after that like no matter where you go
if you're gonna farm at that weekend you
start you kind of have that tag you're
saying and your matchmaking is like
three or four winds above your typical
matchmaking and just kind of slowly
skews you to eventually to the top but I
mean they get the armor gloats based on
going flawless or not for the week yeah
so it could be the same thing like if
your glow is on guess what dude your win
5 Plus last year we had like you get the
final who are farther ahead of the game
because guess what you've done this
already you've proven exactly you
there's already something built-in to
tag you yeah so just apply this with
it's match me or and that's the thing to
like I'm not a game dev I have no I
the level of stuff that has to go in to
make that work right but there already
is something in the game that can mark
us so if there is a way to do that with
matchmaking I think that could be that
could maybe be a decent band-aid yeah
there is it identified sure you agree
with you Dobby we're sitting here we're
armchair and everything a little bit we
don't say we don't know how hard it is
to do such a thing like I said the fact
that there is something in place
hopefully is something that they can you
know address what the feedback they were
given and it makes it again just slight
change listen I haven't I'm not just
weak it should sound like it complains
I'm having a ball playing trial like I
am saying happy sayings back I don't
want to make it seem like this is you
know me bitching every minute whatever
it is anything which is again slight
little tweaks to get it back to you know
just the perfection you know and other
than that I'm good to go but I'm having
a ball I can't wait for it to be
released yeah that's gonna happen to
Katy no yes I mean I'm with you guys I'm
not I haven't honestly touched trials
yet because I gotta get a group together
yeah
you wanna play tonight yeah I mean
you're welcome to if you want man
there's if you got space in a backpack
that's probably where I'm gonna need to
find now let's say the back you gotta
pull your weight man you know it's like
any time I've ever even played the one
time I went to the lighthouse I got like
there was backpack involved I mean I had
a couple like you know decent okay
moments and stuff like that but the two
I was playing with were vastly above my
skill even in that though I was like
I'll still give it my best I'm just like
don't expect me to be on like the elite
level is biggest thing all hours I'm so
it is still one of the most fun Mo's the
strategy II not getting paid support
your teammates you know there's so much
involved and you know when you get that
pic sometimes Russian protecting arms it
the game within the game you know and it
seems but it is so much to it and it
it's just satisfying and I'm saying it's
it's a really fun thing whenever you
start get Beaumont's about pulling
things off and I just realized that I
like playing with people for a good stay
makes my life oh good well my job is
guard duty if you put them down I will
guard that or get you skill that is my
jar if they bought him you finish it
yeah man I'm coming to a team shatter
your support your support cloud support
that's a legit position within playing
trials like yeah yeah thing to that's
it's one of the things that like can
really help people try to find how
they're gonna fit like if you're you
know if you can snipe sweet be the
sniper but if you're like man I just I
can't snipe oh cool man just like
whoever your dude is rushing be his
battle buddy that's what you got to do
about yeah be his friend like be glued
to the hip because there's still
overwhelming when you see two Guardians
rounding a corner unless you're gonna
get a really good nade or like mmm some
kind of collateral or something most
gonna trade one two one one of them is
going to come out on top so giving
you're giving your team a chance to have
those two V ones and at least get a
trade is worth it anything honestly I
just want to ask what do you think I
think it's gonna be trials map this
weekend man we're gonna know in a cut
ours set out a little bit you said
what's gonna be work what's gonna be the
trials map for this weekend what do you
think oh the name of that one
it's the Earth Map they it's a new one
they brought back it's a smaller map
there's a the one that was the
PlayStation exclusive I was the name of
that one X blue is fine that's a good
Charles man oh yeah I was like widows
court this week that'd be cool what else
the strategy for sure because I think
what does court would be a good one just
to make people be quiet about hard light
because because sniping will be like
definitely a I think you'd honestly see
a lot of pulses and scouts for that week
maybe some pain it might go figure
yeah honestly a pricey apart see that a
lot of blast furnaces and stuff I think
you would see it I think you would good
yeah I was like in tight I just don't
have the blast furnace role that will
replace my go figure
never get a good on all it might have
been treasured by feeding frenzy rampage
yeah basically yeah that's that's what I
was I do we just don't seem to make yeah
yeah I could not get those wrong I got
lucky I was like yes golden as long as
I'm not a feeding frenzy really worked
yeah my hammer head was like feeding
frenzy rampage on my like second or
third like on my second or third I've
had that thing forever so believe me
when I hit that jackpot I was like well
I can kiss all the other forged weapons
goodbye cuz I got done and I haven't had
like you've got your kindled orchid
rampage kill clip though don't you
now you got when I got I just wish yeah
I need to get wasn't one it's good it's
solid no I just wish it was a wolf in
here I guess I read actually like you to
be better because like I said you got
that rampage you got the kill clip I
throw a rampage spec on that bad boy
extending man and I'm doing all type of
multiplicative damage I'm just it's
crazy like having are the only gun that
has rampage and kill clip the other
nothing else going wrong with that
thanks so is there anything else for
trials that you guys want to cover
thoughts about it at all besides waiting
to see what the maps gonna be map and I
think we definitely need to see a way to
combat token farming a little bit at
least for people that have gone flawless
I think that would it that would bring
some faith back but also knowing because
of everything that's going on with kovat
and you know Seattle having people work
from home who knows how fast that could
even be a thing because I'm sure that
requires a lot of work
maybe being in the office to implement
yeah so I don't know when a healthy time
is to even hope for something like that
but it was something that I think would
bring some faith and think that okay
we're moving in a direction to ensure a
fun experience for everybody and my last
point is pleased with the dam beavers
other animals leave what she thought
about that because it destroyed me last
I got kicked out of so many matches
shout out to my boy Emmett ash and put
his video out this yeah the same
experience he'd literally ate beavers in
a role playing from he ain t verse wait
that's a last word after dart podcast
they got enough Janet ammonia for city
they got a nerf beaver
yeah bringing random animal I don't know
what a tapir was until reservoir I need
more unique animal names keep the errors
just give me different names be like hey
if there's ever a cheetah I'm gonna be
like well what did I do dammit
yeah I want an elephant shrew error
please okay that would be ultra specific
be like you found it the sub coder is
like make it like Pokemon dude you could
have a whole like triumphalist for how
many airs you can have your own seal
just like killed by the architect seal
also has to have a counter for the
number of times you've been killed by
the drop yes yeah oh yeah stronger by
the way have you ever been team killed
by a teammate from shoulder charging you
into a wall in trials because I have why
shoulders have pushed you into a hard
enough to kill yes the the inertia of
somehow it knocked me out damn he was
crazy it was on anomaly I was like
you've got to be kidding kind of tight
in there but yeah that's that's a new
one yeah like it can be done you can TK
your teammates because it's like punting
the chest you know it's the right way
like it's like if you were falling down
the map the game registers you're moving
really quickly and hitting a surface
yeah yeah that's a good roll those
bunker slides where you find the jump
perfectly glide and I love that now I
will definitely say I actually wanted to
ask you guys cuz I thought about this
earlier totally blew past it we were
talking about the consoles and stuff
like the bunkers are a prime example of
the way all the games are built at this
point we have to go down this tiny
little corridor while it unloads the
world out here while it loads the thing
in front of us as they think about you
know the faster SSDs and all these crazy
powerful consoles like what do you truly
picture like if we'd you know d3 is in
the works then no they've got that power
to work with and they know of that speed
of the SSD is in the loading like it's
it we've had depth for so long I
honestly don't know if I can picture
what play
games are just gonna be completely like
just the navigation of a games gonna
feel completely different I think yeah I
mean I would anticipate a lot less
loading times or if they happen they're
gonna be pretty instantaneous you know
almost like you know when division
dropped you know being able to go from
inside to outside you're not seeing a
look at this like I think you'll see
more things like that they may force you
to slow down during it maybe for a brief
moment like you can't sprint during that
load time but you're still in the world
and that change is happening yeah I
would expect maybe things like that I
think in the beginning though it's just
like any new console life cycle you're
not gonna see the full power until
you're a couple years and like right now
we're seeing the true capability got a
war on PlayStation oh no we didn't see
that till near the end of the lifecycle
same with you know in my lab yeah we're
gonna only what is what could be a
next-gen game but is the very end of
this cycle too hard to say it's a good
question you know I mean I get excited
about that type of stuff in tech you
know just having destiny with new tools
new graphical fidelity more RAM all
these things that make the world more
expensive that excites me you know I'm
just excited even you know once this new
generation starts that console guys are
actually going to experience what you
put me on to the gloriousness of nvme
SSD like oh like they have no idea like
it's so much fun to play on PC and then
you know the tips come by you don't even
get to read maybe one or two tips that
they've added and then you're already
their life and also exactly where on
console I can read a whole you know
scripture of all the big slow that go to
the bathroom come back you don't say
like no it can be painful yeah I
remember helping my father-in-law do it
a forge on console and I was like oh
brother
boy I'm hoping for 60 FPS for everybody
your eyeballs will be so happy it
literally I still play on console every
now and then and it literally feels like
yeah games that will play on console
yeah it's like I'll play games that are
on there like neo or certain ones that
are PlayStation and they're kind of
Layton and even with neo oh my god like
I started it
first and it was in movie mode but I'd
like I've got a ps4 pearl and I switched
it over to like action mode and it just
I was watching it was stream and I was
like oh my god it was just so much
better so I'm like the eye-opening
experience when they go 60 frames
destiny and the field of view is like
they're gonna be like is this the same
game that cross SAV is gonna be the best
thing ever
oh yeah oh yeah not even the same game
won't even be close and that's yeah
that's I don't know is just sitting
there thinking it's like cuz the bunkers
especially the moon one the earth one is
just like drive down turn turn and
you're down the moon one is like you
know and like it takes so many like
turns to go down like why do you guys
have to make these things so hard to get
into or why a spider like twelve yards
farther back than he ever needs to be I
know it's all the tricks of loading but
it's just they have to have its ol along
so he can dump instead of memory and
bring it in
but yeah you were talking about the MV
me a normal even 7200 rpm hard drive
reads and writes data but like a hundred
and twenty megabytes per second and then
like the envy amis we're talking about
or gonna be either twenty times that at
about twenty four hundred two four three
four thousand or if you go PS five it's
like 40 times that like those are crazy
fast it's just like they don't even know
what bad them it right like you can pass
it in what we currently using right now
yeah the PC idea for the only ones that
are even like even on the ps4 is for ps5
slate level are the Samsung ones because
those are like yeah 6000 to 8000 they're
not even out yet yeah so like those are
the ones that you might be able to plop
in there but both of those consoles are
gonna be crazy powerful between SSDs and
all the teraflops and everything but now
dude I'm looking forward to everything
on those that'll be right now honestly
mostly because if they can make destiny
3 and I'm really hoping I know it's not
gonna happen because if they make a
destiny 3 but they don't want it like
not sell destiny 3 to a hundred million
people or 150 million people I love that
cutoff I wish I wish I want that because
I want that game built for net for
fusion but it's like why do it I don't
know Bungie go run away from that money
well
million consoles the yeah they want to
sell it to and I'm just like don't
develop for the old stuff but I know
there has to be a cut-off and I almost
wonder - because I saw Chris Barrett has
a a redacted title and what he's working
for at Bungie anymore
like if you go - yeah we're going on
matter or do you think they work it
don't matter
that's probably matter its matter
actually what it's called now that's the
code name that's the code name yeah he
could be he could be mmhmm yeah he'll be
manner right now they're split day
they're like three teams right now
mm-hmm
d3 new IP of Manor and then I actually
call the BT Dubbs the BT miles like
they're the a-team already so they are
very ambitious BT but I'm glad that they
exist I mean it's a big company man
there's like hundreds of people working
there now sure I'm just going to say
like just random bunny tree I'm just
really curious what the game is even
gonna be like if it's gonna be anything
remotely near a shooter if it's gonna
I'm honestly thinking it's something
totally different so they can get
totally different some type of wit
actually has a light this new gaze would
have like a light like on the cool
comical yep I don't want to say
overwatch II but I don't play as a video
out on it and what these the tea leaves
that he has gathered on this game so
definitely a departure from serious you
know my artist to have that kind of
change though that'll be good for their
brains just to think about it a whole
totally different headspace that'll be
good for him it'll keep their minds
right yeah well we had the lightest wob
probably ever in a while the only thing
that basically is changing is the update
coming next month is gonna be working on
adding seasonal mods to the all the
armor they dumped into the game yes
smart needs to happen
makes it viable drops I swear almost
a triumph armor that they didn't yeah
there's so many pinnacle drops that are
like just world drops and I get those
I'm like oh cool it's good stats doesn't
matter I got a 63 stat roll on this
thing because it doesn't have a mod that
I want to go use oh right yeah those are
those are being added they've got some
fixes they're working on quite a few of
them
not bad ones actually just little stuff
that probably should have been there
like the legendary lost sector not
awarding a powerful drop the season
passed like 92 is not where rank 92 is
not working for everybody with getting
those drops in there Reggie's harness
with the whirlwind guard indefinitely
kind of breaking one of the supers the
Titan the season pass armor you can't
see a damn thing with a bow have you
guys seen that I mean yes I saw a video
oh you have great ornament I just got
the ornament cuz it's somewhere and
whatever rake up near the shoulder the
crazy Russians like army showing it
clips into your fov it blinds you you're
here it's like clipped up to about like
half eye and then if you fully draw it's
the whole damn thing you cannot see
anything you are in the shoulder pad
yeah so I kind of like that that's
that's kind of that's kind of boss like
it's definitely Titan style with the big
shoulder pads like embracing it but yeah
you got a hipfire from that point on
otherwise you better like hope you're
aiming at what you want to and just pull
it blind release cuz it's I tried it no
it's like oh my god it's real I was in
the shoulder and assist help me yeah
yeah mostly just quite a few fixes even
just like you know the planetary
materials coming from the bunker which
is one of those upgrades is giving you
like one I think so it's actually
supposed to be gathering and doing all
that stuff so mostly it's just a good
amount of fixes another twitch primer
Ward dropped we got prometheus lens the
ornament for prometheus lens a shell and
a ship so if you have twitch prime go
ahead get your rewards they're nice and
easy yeah if you got twitch prime sub to
captain fly sub to iron Lords podcast
sub to me if you want to but at least
those two first use it on somebody at
least it's it's free money and a free
way to give somebody some love
absolutely Amazon can can afford to give
it yeah the Papa Amazon is making is the
one company making all the money right
now so please make sure you spend some
of those
for sure but yeah I was like lightest
[ __ ] ever I know he talked uh so I wanted
to kind of get back I know you had
mentioned one of your topics of
discussion was just kind of like the
idea of a fourth subclass that you had
kind of thought about I was like so
would it be like
damage type like would you want like a
agree a different color like a
completely different feel or just
another fourth like little option of
like the way we got the taken king we
got the hammers do you want now if I'm a
solar guy what am I gonna run around
with like solar swords as a tech nerd
like no way were you taking those I was
curious to me I'm looking at it like you
know based on the cutscenes we got at
the end so spoilers if you haven't seen
the end of the cutscene or shadow keep
at this point but honestly even not like
knowing that there have been guardians
that have meddled with the darkness you
know like Toland and stuff like that I
would love to see a darkness inspired
subclass so whether that's quote-unquote
poison and it's green or I honestly
think you go black like almost like take
in almost like black and peels and
whites I think that'd be kind of cool
cuz like in a way you're almost
embracing like a Star Wars vibe of like
a gray Jedi or something like that and
so having like a mishmash of the
different subclasses with a darkness
twist to it so maybe it doesn't have a
burn but maybe it has like a smoke
grenade effect and so it's like a cloud
and a slow or something like that
different kinds of maybe it's more of
like a debuff centric class or something
like that you know to where you have
even more roles like you know because we
now finally have healing roles within
you know the warlock right back right
having someone that could say all right
I'm focused on debuff so I'm working on
like you know neutralizing the enemies
or turning the tide whether it's from a
PvE or even a PvP perspective I think it
would be kind of interesting and I think
it could work within the lore of the
game without straight-up having to write
new lore like we have Guardian
and exiled from idling in it or have you
know a lot been lost to the corners of
time because they've been investigating
the darkness too hard I think they could
ever actually pull a world of like horde
verse Alliance like dark versus light
and you actually pick which side you
start the game on do you think they
could ever go that far I mean they tried
to do with Vanguard and
you know with regard in the drifter so
maybe you'll see maybe that'll pan out
maybe that's kind of part of that thing
if you picked drifter you'll have that
as a subclass option and if you picked
along if you have don't know what you
did yeah I don't know that's one of
those things - it's like what was the
purpose maybe done yeah like dialogue
things that we still get like we haven't
seen the payoff on that yet if we will
at all so it's hard to say on that until
we actually see it but I would say that
I think it would be cool that that would
be something I would like to see is like
something that could bring in a fourth
that's completely different from the
others it's kind of more of like an
overall debuff or maybe it's a damage
over time style thing or you know like
maybe built on like suppression or like
anti light basically like it's you know
all the nades are built on like
suppression AIDS or things like clouding
or taking away supers or maybe draining
super energy and converting it to yours
any type of like vampiric abilities of
like stealing and stealing energy
stealing grenade energy from like
exactly like maybe that's you don't have
a super like you forego a light given
super with the intent of pulling light
from others that could maybe be the way
that you balance it is that this person
you never get a super but you're all
built on depriving your opponent from
their super from their light given
abilities I think that man that would be
that reminds me of like all the other
classes in the dread night that came
into world Warcraft was like that
completely different feel so mm-hmm that
that would be cool Donn's like I I do
either one and with you with you for
subclass like some different style I
would like to see a little more depth on
the scale trees - coming from world in
Diablo into many games like just the one
little sugar pick or pick like just a
little more you know intention of like
how I want to play do I want like you
know do I want the Devastator mall but I
want to have you know something like
sunspots or something is there a way to
mix and match some pieces of those
things would be nice to see as well a
little bit of righty there so cookie
cutter right now it's one of the other
they are but at the same time like you
gotta know that you're not appealing to
you got a you got to try to find a way
to make sure it's approachable but also
give build options yeah there'd be a lot
of balancing that needs to happen with
stuff like that to make sure you're like
you're not straight up like super
braking that's a lot more gift imbalance
yeah but I agree like more more player
agency for your super decisions would be
cool no shadows like yeah destiny one
trees do you though do you really are
you telling me okay I'm alright so
you're telling me chat that you used
every single node in d1 skill trees if
you are you're a liar to the belt but if
there were more but so many of them did
nothing like the okay but that's kind of
a big like if they take a subclass that
was you know way of the Devastator like
the burning mall was not much for a
while
picture that is a couple nodes well if
they go through and buff those nodes up
and at least like it makes them look and
be like hey what nodes aren't used well
I can look at a heat map and it looks
like a touch screen on a password thing
and there's only six or seven that are
used there's about twelve that aren't
okay let's look at why those aren't good
and see if we can make them viable at
least to give you I mean they would
cheer you that type of balancing but but
they did with these subclasses though
they said okay cool these now have three
different playstyles for this class of
super or this element type but but the
negative to it is that it locks you into
a permanent style it doesn't give you
any flexibility whereas even though I do
like the d2 styles right now I'm not
actually like the different choice at
least for war like I don't have a
complain but I do miss that option at E
is talking about which is you know in d1
I remember running with Sun what is it
son what was it the one to resurrect
whatever Samsung son second so yeah and
you know you had like you know different
this type of melee and I had you know
Viking funeral you you could do some
tweaking even now with the Nova I was
picking what super I was using the one
that leaves all underneath you know yeah
what was it drastic no but it was some
game playing changing things that I
liked having you know some effect on it
would be cool I mean we do know they're
calling it an MMO now officially
embracing it they want to get more Luke
Smith has come out openly and said they
really want to get into those roots
those you know those type of that type
of mentality for d3 it'll be cool I mean
into your point yes I would love a
darkness class that's literally you know
what I'm shooting for I mean literally
what you're saying is quote unquote what
was leaked by our good friend was his
name and they know you know the night is
goin on Pig yeah you know like that
stuff was leaked in apparently they were
talking about like Evie e - e ve prefer
BPPV
things that would be crazy actually
mm-hmm to see yep world and being around
he'd be like dark well it's a dark
Guardian and be like I'll do I got him
and just like you get nailed while
you're working on a quest like that was
a thinking world like I remember certain
Western lately yeah yeah Eastern Western
Plaguelands where was that point where
you're kind almost high enough there
could be some elite people up then
you're like I'm scared attention it was
and let's be honest like it does fit
with the lore when you finish gardener
salvation raid and obviously the shadow
keep but those who haven't played it by
now if you haven't seen base but you
know at the end of the day you know this
is something it's appealing to us it's
it's saying you know we're not this
enemy that you think we are right so
this is a this is a way they could
introduce it and I would like that and
the things that you were saying about
the debuff being oh man that sounds easy
style really yeah really cool you could
do like poisoning and stuff like that
and that's why I was like a picture
green is the color that is very much not
used in the subclasses and was a big
standout to separate it's almost almost
feels like a dredging or thorn glass
there's a really dark evil you know just
complete opposite of the light in tone
and ability and visual representation
that will be by never sure get you talk
Stefan mmm
well I don't want to keep this man too
long we are coming up on two hours gonna
make sure this man can do his work world
so ya know was just trying to let you go
so I know we can really go along so
appreciate you guys for having me
absolutely so if you want to just kind
of tell them where you at when to expect
to you best places to find you give in
your little bit of shout out here table
as your sir sure so so if you do want to
find me I do stream on Twitch three
nights a week Monday Wednesday Friday
nights
eight o'clock central we primarily play
destiny occasionally we'll do different
stuff but if you want to know what we're
gonna play you can always find me on
Twitter at captain McFly TV and also if
you're into eSports and you want to
check out some of the shows we're
producing you can search us for envy TV
pretty much anywhere the shows we
produce are contested for overwatch
League off the break for the Call of
Duty League you can find us on youtube
you can find us on podcast or Spotify
Apple podcasts we're a little bit of
everywhere so anywhere you could find
that kind of stuff for free to to check
me out and the stuff I'm working on wrap
it up real quick on yours and then we
will get this exit done Jimmy you
already know it look how you don't want
witih and of course on our podcast every
Sunday please catch us this Sunday 1
p.m. Eastern on the Iowa caucus youtube
we shall have built Stillwell from the
Microsoft Project X cloud team and our
back compasso will be good to beat dies
with him on the new tech see what's
going on with the Xbox series X and all
that kind of stuff so check us out
Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern and also Iowa
podcast channel my boy King David's got
some cool statues up into Marvel home
statues and things of that nature he's
got some cool stuff up please check that
out and of course Lords of gaming got
net and last but not least he hates what
I say this the best day for the podcast
you've never heard on Friday morning
shut me down the best destiny podcast
you haven't heard yet Friday waters bad
check us out they're really cool first
of all a salute got to its life coming
through great to hear your story great
to actually chop with you it was really
cool and again salute to the chat a lot
of fun and that's all I got bit yeah I
mean me I'm shelter-in-place so I am
literally streaming pretty much a lot
all the time my wife wants to see me a
little more but trying to do this as
much as I can as doing the other part of
my job a little less because I can't
actually go into work
so you guys find me a lot on Twitch and
then of course making a lot of videos
you guys can find me on Twitter it's a
bond test everywhere if you find the
cheetah you probably found me
so captain will fly again as well for me
thank you chat you guys have been
awesome but you have been a pleasure to
have on you or welcome back anytime sir
especially and we also definitely got to
get that lunch / Cheers going on because
yet we're too close not allowed to leave
our houses hundred-person yeah we can
get out to the world yeah go take a walk
at least but we always try and do this
like timing and with discord it's
impossible but I'm gonna leave a big
pause when I wrap it up to say and it
has been and we say the last word
together so alright yeah I'll wrap this
thing up so for episode 96 we are
creepin closer to 100 which is actually
really cool
March 27 thank you guys very much shots
been awesome stay tuned don't go
anywhere Chad I'm gonna send you guys
over raid one of other dusting channels
but for episode 96 thank you guys for
this episode it has been the last word